spider-man no way home because of the post-credits
scene so i'll address that too with all these big
you have not seen venom let there be carnage yet
because we'll be talking about everything during
this new deleted scene that sony released they get
into a much bigger mythology behind the symbiotes
the klintar race tease a much bigger story about
taking over planet earth like a planet of the
symbiote storyline or a marvel universe venomized
storyline for those of you that remember when they
venomized most of the marvel universe a couple
years ago and just the whole concept of the god
of confirmed some of those theories with them
trying to lay track work setting up knull in
a larger cosmic backstory of the symbiotes
80 billion light years of hive knowledge
across universes just the smallest fraction of
the things we symbiotes have experienced the whole
clip of him talking about 80 billion light years
of hive knowledge across the multiverse melting
eddie brock's mind is all about the true origin
of the symbiotes in the way their race works
the other cool easter egg in here too is that
when he's talking about hive knowledge across the
multiverse and he says that guy when spider-man
pops up on the tv after he crosses into the mcu
it's him tapping into the hive memories from
the topher grace venom from the tobey maguire
spider-man 3 movie remembering his fight with
spider-man from that movie but when he's talking
about 80 billion light years the way they're using
it is sort of a combination of time and distance
now a light year is a unit of distance but the
symbiote is also trying to tell eddie about
the history of their race so he's also using
it as a unit of time the symbiotes do have a
hive mind connection but all of them are able
to exist as separate individual personalities
it just there's like this deep cosmic link built
into their dna that hardwires them all together
across universes of the multiverse so for example
the venom symbiote in this movie this version
has its own individual memories it accumulated
since its spawn but it can also tap into the
memories from other symbiotes and other universes
like i said it can tap into the memories of topher
grace's venom symbiote from spider-man 3. the
actual name of the symbiotes race is called
the klyntar and the way they're organized their
hierarchy is they're all kind of like worker bees
that each have a little more individuality more
independence but ultimately they're capable of
being controlled as a group by a single primal
symbiote it's sort of like a lord of the rings
situation with the one ring of power the symbiotes
are like the many other rings of power they're all
very powerful in their own right but ultimately
they're slaves to the one ring to the primal
symbiote in the primal symbiote was created by
knull god of the symbiotes after the big bang
after the birth of the universe or multiverse
if you want to get technical so knull is one
of these cosmic gods who came into existence
in the void of chaos before the big bang he
was born in sort of the void of nothingness that
the dark elves came from in thor the dark world
also remember the eternals movie with the origin
of the celestials ereshan the judge was kind of
lying a little bit about his origin story but he
said he also predates the big bang so technically
he was also born in that void that knull was
born in there's also a huge connection between
nol and the celestials too but noel was just this
powerful cosmic god during this chaotic period
but then the big bang happens eternity comes into
existence as the living embodiment of the universe
the infinity stones are formed from the
singularities left after the big bang and then
the real story of the celestials that airshim was
not telling the eternals is that he was created by
eternity and then he creates the first sun the
first galaxy forms and then airshim the judge
starts creating the rest of the celestial hosts
with those cosmic seeds over millions of years
and while the celestials were doing that while
that was getting started after the big bang no
rebels against eternity wanting to destroy the
universe and take things back to the dark void
of chaos is basically the exact same plant that
the dark elves had during thor the dark world same
basic idea so with the dawn of the universe no
goes around just warring with the celestials that
existed at that time to try and stop them from
creating more galaxies creating more celestials in
order to do that he takes a piece of his body full
of cosmic energy and that piece of himself becomes
a weapon that he names the primal symbiote that's
why he's called the god of the symbiotes because
he created their race from himself all the other
regular symbiotes that came after were spawned
from the primal symbiote which is why anyone
who bonds with the primal symbiote can control
all symbiotes across all of existence across the
multiverse that would sort of be like an avengers
endgame iron man infinity gauntlet kind of moment
for the venom character in tom hardy's venom maybe
sony can build up to that if they work real hard
venom saves the multiverse kind of end game moment
having eddie brock in venom bond with the primal
symbiote one ring to rule them all but then what
happened is that noel takes that primal symbiote
fashions it into a sword to kill the celestials
later the sword is found by gore the god butcher
who calls it the necro sword and uses it to go
around killing all the regular gods of the marvel
universe we're going to see christian bale playing
a version of gore the god butcher during thor 4
love and thunder they'll do a version of the necro
sword but i'm not expecting the thor people to
connect that to knull or the primal symbiote based
on marvel and sony's sharing deal for spider-man
in the terms of how all that's supposed to work
with their crossovers with venom and spider-man
characters the idea is that if sony wanted to they
could probably make gore the god butcher necro
sword references during a knull storyline if they
did it on their side but marvel and sony kind of
let each other use easter eggs however they want
they don't force each other to include easter eggs
one of the exceptions being what's happening with
the symbiote in venom in spider-man no way home
i'll address that at the end of the video too
because of what's happening with the post-credits
scene like very clearly they're trying to tell us
that venom is crossing over with spider-man but
just in terms of venom in spider-man no way home
so obviously during the venom lethargy carnage
post-credits scene they set up him crossing
into the mcu and now on the spider-man side of
things in the mcu they have to acknowledge that
right now the rumor is that what's going to happen
is that eddie brock will just be inadvertently
sent back to his original universe when doctor
strange eventually fixes everything with the
multiverse spell but supposedly according to these
rumors he will leave the venom symbiote behind
so that they could use it for a spider-man
symbiote saga in future mcu spider-man movies
the good news is that the movie is coming out in
a couple weeks we won't have to wait that long to
find out what they're actually doing but everyone
post all your theories in the comments below do
you think that sony will eventually be able to
work up to a knull storyline in their movies the
other big thing that's happening right now is that
the hawkeye episodes just started i just posted my
episode 1 and episode 2 video so i'll add links
down in the description and at the end of this
my hawkeye episode 3 video will post next week
there'll be a bunch more spider-man no way home
videos posting too everyone click here for my
brand new spider-man no way home trailer video
with more tobey maguire easter eggs and click here
for my full hawkeye episode 1 in episode 2 video
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!